no matter what game you play there's
something you hate playing against who
we saw what the [__] is this operator
most of the time it's something cheesy
or broken
you'll get literally one shot somebody
the right click I don't care how
inaccurate it is it's better than a
[__] Zeus man but sometimes you hate
something not because it's good but
because it shouldn't be because
seemingly everything about its creation
was intended to be as irritating
frustrating and rage-inducing as humanly
possible sometimes you play against a
monster and anyone who picks Teemo is
that monster make no mistake Teemo one
of League of Legends and most iconic
characters was designed to be an
annoying little [__] he's barely fun to
play ass let alone to play against and
sometimes it feels like he's literally
only in the game to troll people who
know better than to pick him it becomes
however unlike most unwanted devil
children there's actually a battle over
his true parentage whether League fans
like it or not their game in its
earliest days wasn't exactly a
wellspring of originality many aspects
of its design including champions out a
lot two concepts developed for DOTA
allstars
the Warcraft 3 mod that preceded dota 2
don't believe me just take a look at ash
and drow Ranger or Corky and gyrocopter
it's kind of shameless really ok stop
copying me so copy me back in its day
the DOTA allstars forums were packed
with dozens of suggestions from
signers and fans for Heroes that never
even made it into dota and one of those
ideas was a wicket the big game hunter
wicket was supposed to be a hard to
catch quick character with crowd control
traps that were annoying to play against
and that shouldn't be a surprise given
that he was based on he walks who aside
from destroying the Emperor with arrows
in a non cannon game mostly existed to
annoy the Empire and also youn the movie
watcher yeah until you see them blank
yeah they're [__] disgusting anyway
wicket was one of the many dota
character concepts that riot allegedly
reworked into one of their early
champions for League of Legends
according to an article on the creation
of Teemo riot producer Jeff Joo says the
design team wanted cute characters in
their roster but also wanted something
that had a gameplay identity that was at
odds with the cute cuddly aesthetic the
adorable characters were named yordles
apparently because a riot artist had a
dream about Yoda and fellow species made
nate'll and use their names together
when he woke up he [__] for a while
teemo's kit was in flux as designers
experimented with everything from a six
second stun dart to a starcraft nuke he
could target from stealth eventually
after more strange and seemingly random
inspiration they equipped a little
bastard with toxic mushrooms
[Music]
timo entered the rift in the sixth week
of league's alpha and early on wasn't
actually that bad of a champion his
purpose was to counter tanky damage
dealers like Garen and though he's
rarely been played competitively he did
see an ironic use in the LCS as late as
2014 Teemo actually beats up on most of
the current top laners in League of
Legends people just haven't started
playing him because they don't think he
transitions into teamfights very well
hilariously riot actually nerf teemo the
next week because even they don't want
to live in a world where teemo is a
viable pick but tony unacquainted what
is it that makes teemo such a pain in
the ass well for starters he has a blind
which gives him more survivability than
a squishy character should ever have he
can become invisible if he sits still he
has damage over time and he can create
invisible mushroom traps that slow and
apply a dot that's [__] to make
matters worse even his personality is
grading his shrill high-pitched laugh is
not only the stuff nightmares are made
of
but it's often used as a global taunt
that universally inspires rage towards a
little scamp
nothing about playing against Teemo is
fun but as lolly volved coordinated
teams have learned to absolutely take
him apart and while his damage output is
high his overall kit doesn't make him
worth picking especially as newer
champions like Nikko are much more
viable choices Teemo is essentially a
peck that tells everyone in the game
that you aren't taking it seriously you
don't give a [__] about actually winning
you're just here to guarantee at least
half an hour of misery for all involved
especially your teammates but who cares
as long as you're having fun right you
are a rude terrible person and the way
you treat other people are horrible
confounding Lee outside of pro play
Teemo remains pretty popular his pick
rate has never completely cratered he
still gets regular skins and outside the
game riot sells tons of Teemo
merchandise including hats that you've
seen it literally every League event
Teemo is basically leagues mascot and
simultaneously a symbol of players
soloqueue travails so with us being
champions for a positive change at the
score eSports we wanted to see if it was
possible to impact the community's
perception of Teemo for the better and
after locking one of our interns in a
room for a week with the direction to
only play Teemo this is what we learned
[Music]
in the end we discovered that despite
your best efforts to be a positive
cooperative team omein the best thing
you can do for everyone involved
including yourself is to not pick him at
all he's straight Garbo
[Music]
someday yeah
he walks are the worst part of Return of
the Jedi were they gonna do man take me
to school
Oh tell my family
[Music]